the movie opens with a scene from the
Ice Age it's freezing outside and a
caveman is seen attempting to make fire
for his lover who is shivering from the
cold suddenly an earthquake strikes and
causes the cave to collapse burying the
two of them the movie then fast forwards
to the present where an average teenager
named Dave Morgan is woken up by an
earthquake in Los Angeles he is a boring
high school kid whose only aim in life
is to be popular and impress his Crush
Robin Sweeney to achieve that Dave is
building a pool in his backyard with the
help of his equally unpopular best
friend Stoney one day while digging his
dream pool Dave comes across a bowl from
the prehistoric era intrigued he starts
digging on that exact spot and soon
discovers a chunk of ice buried
underground surprisingly it contains a
well-preserved body of a prehistoric man
the finding takes Dave over the moon as
he believes that he will finally become
popular now he immediately calls his
friend Stoney and the two of them pull
the ice block out of the ground shortly
after they leave it in the garage around
some space heaters so that the ice can
mouth later that day at school Dave
invites his Crush Robin to check out
something special that he has found but
sadly she turns him down he is
completely oblivious that Robin is
already dating someone an arrogant jock
named Matt hence when Matt sees the nerd
hitting on his girlfriend he carries
Dave and pins him on the notice board
making him a laughing stock meanwhile
back in Dave's Garage the heaters melt
the ice and surprisingly the prehistoric
caveman is found to be alive as he falls
on the ground he is puzzled by his new
environment which looks like nothing
short of an alien planet to him hence he
starts wandering around the property to
make sense of everything at first he
comes across Dave's dog and plays with
him for a while but suddenly a
helicopter passes by scaring him away
from the place he then Ventures around
the neighborhood where he notices a
modern human and takes up a defensive
position once the man runs away the
caveman tries drinking water from a
nearby drain but immediately spits it
out because of its bad taste after a
while the garbage truck arrives and the
caveman takes it from Mammoth and tries
scaring it away way he even throws a
shovel at it while screaming like a
maniac fed up with the new world the
caveman enters Dave's residence and
starts dancing to some rock songs that
are being played on TV later when Dave
returns home with Stoney they find hand
paint covering the walls and the house
in disarray with the caveman missing
from sight suddenly the fire alarm goes
off and they discover the caveman in
Dave's bedroom trying to light a fire
with sticks the two friends hurriedly
enter the room and try to introduce
themselves but they end up freaking him
out just then the phone also rings and
the caveman starts jumping on the bed
like a madman he also lunges towards
Dave to attack him but Stoney comes to
the rescue with a lighter surprisingly
the man-made fire impresses the caveman
and he finally calms down following this
the boys decide to integrate the caveman
into their society at first they give
him a bath they empty several bottles of
body wash and conditioner to scrub the
man clean they also trim his hair and
dress him like an average teenager then
after a lot of deliberation Dave decides
to name him link because he feels the
caveman is the missing leg between him
and high school popularity after the
makeover as the boys are trying to
introduce themselves they hear Dave's
Family's car pulling up in the driveway
panicked David struck Stoney to take
Link out and ring the doorbell
pretending as if they have just arrived
he then heads to the kitchen and takes
the fall for trashing the whole place he
tells his parents that he wanted to
surprise them by cooking dinner
meanwhile link and Stoney show up at the
door the parents are perplexed to see
the new kid acting strangely but just as
they are about to interrogate him Dave
Cuts them off he frantically lies that
link is an exchange student from Estonia
who doesn't speak a word of English He
further mentions that his school is
giving out extra credit points to the
students who are housing foreign
exchange students at first the parents
are skeptical about letting link into
their home but when Dave emotionally
blackmails that it's for his career they
reluctantly agree the next day an
excited Dave takes link to his high
school and enrolls him in class while
Stony is a genuine guy who just wants to
be friends with the caveman Dave wants
to teach him stupid pet tricks to
entertain others his only goal is to use
the new guy to gain popularity 30. if
Dave wants to impress everyone with a
trick you should just show them the one
where he takes the ring to Mordor
shortly after in the school hall link
notices Robin and her friend Cindy
enamored by their beauty he makes his
way towards them jumping from the first
floor using his Supreme athletic skills
he is Amazed by Cindy's physique and
proceeds to touch her but Dave quickly
intervenes and escorts him away however
the girls are already intrigued by
Link's bizarre behavior in the next
scene while Dave is busy with his
classes Stoney takes link to his Spanish
class there Cindy continuously hits on
link and even asks him out girls really
do be into neanderthals though after the
class is over Stoney takes the caveman
to his favorite store to treat him to
his favorite burrito there he also
introduces different types of chocolates
and teaches link how to wheeze the juice
following this the two go to an
amusement park and ride on a roller
coaster by the time link returns home he
has learned to speak a bit like Stoney
during dinner the caveman continues to
act strange like he eats a fly and also
Chows on some dog food but luckily they
Dave's family is already used to this
later that night Dave and Stoney take
link to an ice hockey game where all the
popular kids including Robin and Cindy
are present Dave gets excited to see his
crush and proceeds towards her but
accidentally steps on a skateboard and
ends up falling on top of her after
shrugging off the embarrassing moment he
shows her a picture from their childhood
when they took a bath together
unfortunately this further enrages Robin
prompting her to immediately seize the
picture meanwhile link continues to act
strange and he draws naked pictures of
women on the ice skating stand Cindy
wonders if the girl in the picture is
Link's girlfriend from Estonia she then
attempts to seduce him by mentioning
that long-distance relationships never
work but link doesn't understand a word
she is saying on the other hand the
bully Matt notices Dave trying to get
close to his girlfriend and immediately
punishes him by dragging him into the
skating rink in front of everyone link
Witnesses all this and goes to confront
the bully but instead gets a solid punch
to his face he has rattled for a while
but contrary to everyone's expectation
link walks away from the fight Davis
puzzled and Stoney explains that cavemen
fight for food and survival not
popularity popularity is survival in
high school though link should have
whooped that guy hearing this Dave vows
to teach links some self-defense moves
so that he can protect himself against
bullies like Matt and at home he shows
him various tapes of wrestling and
martial arts link quickly picks up the
fighting skills much to the disapproval
of Stoney one day Dave's School takes
his class on a trip to a natural history
museum link finds the giant prehistoric
models familiar but soon he realizes
that cave people he knew are all dead he
becomes upset and starts randomly
yelling but before he can cause any
Mayhem Stoney and Dave calm him down
they also let him know that they are
always there for him as a family as the
three Bond a suspicious mat watches them
from a distance the next day at school
link is paired with Robin in her
driver's ed class seeing link getting in
the driving seat from a distance Stoney
and Dave panic and they rush to stop him
they somehow managed to get in the car
but link starts driving at a high speed
he also performs dangerous stunts that
he saw on TV much to people's amusement
and horror after a bit of chaos inside
the school perimeter link Ventures out
onto the main road and jumps multiple
red lights then he notices a club and
immediately pulls over indicating that
he wants to have some fun reluctantly
the group also follows link to the club
and finds him performing some slick
moves Robin is amazed and she asks Dave
to accompany her on the dance floor but
he turns her down citing his poor
dancing skills as a result she proceeds
to dance with link who slowly starts
becoming the center of attention
meanwhile Sony and Dave befriend a group
of Spanish-speaking men who let them try
alcohol elsewhere Matt and his bully
friends have snuck inside school at
night to find more information about
link they check his medical records and
notice that link has a disease history
of an animal Matt has left further
puzzled by the Revelation but he vows to
his friends to get to the root of it
back in the club Dave watches with
jealousy as link dances his heart out
with Robin just then the police show up
sending everyone at the club into a
frenzy realizing that they are there to
arrest them they've instructs Stoney to
take robin home while he convinces link
to leave however before he can do so the
police arrest the two of them in the
meantime Stoney and his Spanish-speaking
friends drop Robin home and she thanks
them for the amazing time soon Matt
shows up and tries to make up with her
it turns out that Robin is angry at Matt
for punching link the other day she asks
him to go away but Matt doesn't listen
instead he asks her out to prom saying
it's a matter of reputation for him
unfortunately for him the statement
further enrages Robin and she calls him
out for always caring about what other
people think then before shutting the
door she reveals that she wants to go
with someone cooler someone who's not
afraid of being themself at the police
station Dave gets to make one phone call
and without thinking twice he calls
Robin he informs her that he's in prison
along with link and has only one call to
explain himself then without further Ado
he asks her to be his prom date but
Robin swiftly turns him down too instead
she wants to go with link as he is very
down to earth and innocent he's also hot
and doesn't speak English this naturally
frustrates Dave so Robin changes her
offer she suggests that they should all
go to prom together but an upset Dave
hangs up the call a while later the two
teenagers are eventually released from
prison and they return home the next
morning Dave wakes link up and covertly
drives him away from the city luckily
Stoney notices them and starts following
the car after covering some distance
Dave stops the car and tells link to go
into the forest for good it turns out
Dave is jealous that link is stealing
Robin away from him he hands him some
coins for his favorite game and sends
him away however before link can go out
of sight Stoney arrives at the scene
Dave asserts that he can't handle the
caveman anymore because ever since the
day he arrived he has only caused pain
and trouble he also suggests that link
is better off with somebody else shocked
Stony B rates Dave and orders him to
call link back but the latter refuses
one thing leads to another and the two
get into a fight on the streets link
sees his best friends fighting and
rushes to stop them he then grabs the
two and reminds them that they are a
family hearing this Dave finally
realizes his his mistake and apologizes
to both link and Stoney for acting
selfish after he is Forgiven the three
reconcile and hug it out later that
night Dave helps link get dressed for
the prom but he decides not to go
himself soon Robin arrives and tries to
convince Dave to come along but he
refuses claiming that he has been
grounded after link and Robin Leave
Stoney stays back with Dave and the two
have drinks near the pool and vowed to
become popular in college but as they're
conversing a jealous mat breaks into
Dave's room to find evidence on link
unfortunately he stumbles upon some
polaroid pictures which reveal that link
is actually a caveman Dave and Stoney
catch wind of the intrusion and rush to
the scene but it's too late as Matt has
already gotten inside of his car he
taunts the duo with the photographs and
reveals that he is going to expose Link
at the prom after he drives away the
worried friends also follow him
meanwhile at the prom Robin and Link
have become the main attraction but as
soon as they are about to be crowned
prom queen and Kang Matt arrives and
tells everyone that link is actually a
caveman however his plan backfires as
the information makes link even more
popular Dave also arrives and tries to
take the pictures back from Matt but
gets punched in the face instead fed up
with the bullying link becomes enraged
and punishes Matt with all the moves he
has learned the crowd also cheers on as
Matt gets tossed around the place like a
ragdoll following this Dave and Robin
make up and the three boys lead the
entire prom in an impromptu caveman
dance they dance until late at night and
then head to Dave's house for a pool
party Dave also gets his Wish by finally
getting to kiss his Crush Robin in the
meantime Stoney and Link find some muddy
prince in the house and become shocked
they silently follow the prince to the
bathroom and to discover a beautiful
cave woman in the bathtub she turns out
to be Link's partner from the beginning
of the film the movie ends as Dave and
Stoney give the cavewoman a makeover
hence making her a new part of the
family subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching